so today thank you for attending I'll be
speaking about writing unit testing for
data science code and how this can help
you with writing production level code
for your projects
we can use this as well all right uh so
just a brief introduction my name is
Nyle Wilson senior data scientist at
Microsoft within the industry Solutions
Engineering Group
so the reason why I'm giving this talk
today is that from a background in
academics I wasn't really writing any
sort of production level code at the
time so once I joined Microsoft it was a
big learning curve and I had to learn a
lot the past few years but I'm really
happy with where I where I've come and
I'm writing code that is being used in a
lot of different customer Solutions So
within industry Solutions engineering we
work with different Enterprise customers
to build a cloud-based machine learning
and AI Solutions and so I've worked in a
variety of different Industries a lot of
different ml domains the past few years
and my learnings that I'm sharing today
are from all these different experiences
and just side note as Sean mentioned PhD
in bioengineering specifically with
brain computer interfaces so if anyone's
interested in that also feel free to
reach out
all right
so what I want to get across in today's
talk is highlighting the value of unit
testing specifically for data science
code it's a concept that exists within
software engineering the software
engineering realm and is not universally
applied within data science currently so
I want to help kind of improve
the use of unit testing here I'll be
covering the key concepts for unit
testing as well as some specific
techniques for how you can apply it
within your work and hopefully Empower
everyone here to start writing tests if
you aren't already
so I just want to start off with a basic
case study this is an actual project
that I worked on a few years ago with
Warner media so Warner media I think of
Warner Brothers Universal Studios like
just the um big big Media Company
and so when you're filming a production
let's say a TV show or a movie there's a
lot that goes into it and when you're
filming you might have something called
a digital daily
which is when you have footage running
continuously from the start of your day
in production all the way to the end so
just one continuous role where you're
having multiple takes and multiple
scenes
so with this it's a long form video and
when it comes to archiving purposes you
don't necessarily want to store
absolutely everything that would cost a
lot and take up a lot of space
so with Warner media they're interested
in helping their archive this more
efficiently determine when uh there are
areas of interest within the footage so
when specific scenes or takes are
happening and then discard the rest
that's not really of Interest or will be
useful
so in this case the project was to use
machine learning to be able to help
create timestamps to help them the
archive us more effectively scrub
through the videos and determine what to
Archive and what not to
so with this example here we're just
showing that we have raw footage and
high level overview we have audio
workstream computer vision workstream
and a metadata extraction kind of
substream from that everything then gets
Consolidated and generated into the
timestamp report
however this is just a high level
overview
if we go a little bit further
here we go
we can see it's a bit more complex
each of the blocks here are different
steps within a pipeline that are
processing the data in some way
there are multiple data scientists
working on this project at the same time
and I'm sorry I realize this is small
there's no you don't need to actually be
able to read the text on here just to
show that it's a it's a lot and if
you're interested in learning more about
the solution itself we do have a blog
post at
aka.mslash CSC Warner media action cut
but with this we can see it's complex
there's a lot of spots where
um there's data being read in and out
from different locations code each of
these blocks are essentially a different
python script so dot Pi files and
there's a lot happening here so
with this sort of Solution that's
complex multimodal a lot of people
working on it how can we quickly
pinpoint errors when something goes
wrong are we you know how can we quickly
address that
are we confident in the code that we're
merging in
and also do we get consistent and
replicable results
so there's a lot that goes into that but
one of the major things that can help
address a lot of these issues is unit
testing
so what is unit testing
when it comes to unit testing it's
essentially making sure that every
little piece of code or each unit is
working as expected
so you can think of it as like a quality
check making sure each of the gears in
your clock is working like small part of
the broader solution
so this is really helpful for
collaborative coding in particular but
it's also useful for when you're just
writing code for yourself as well so it
really helps with reproducibility as
well as helps reduce debugging time
um and it's just generally like a really
good practice I do want to take a moment
to note that there are other sorts of
tests out there as well there's
integration testing smoke testing Etc
which are also important but today I'll
be focusing on unit tests in particular
so when are they written this depends on
who you ask and what sort of work that
you're working on so if you're doing a
lot of exploratory data analysis and not
moving things to production you might
not be writing tests a lot depending on
your practices
however if you're working on a lot of
production level code writing things to
go out to be deployed using CI CD then
you are most likely writing you to test
at that stage
so depending on who you speak to there
are different opinions on when you
should write them for for various good
reasons
so in this example here we're showing
the different highly generalized flow of
a machine learning or data science
lifecycle you have exploratory data
analysis to proof of concept development
minimally viable product to production
and so for the few first few steps there
we see that unit testing is optional it
could still be helpful for what you're
working on but is not usually required
at that stage
when it comes to creating the minimally
viable product it's definitely
encouraged that you start writing tests
at this point if you haven't already
just to ensure that as you're getting
ready to to go to production you know
things are already nicely in place
so alternatively
there is test driven development as well
or tdd
which is the practice of writing the
tests first or kind of immediately as
you're writing your functions that
you're going to be testing
so this can be really helpful but when
it comes to the nature of data science
work a lot of stuff is really
exploratory we don't always end up using
the code we write in the beginning in
the end so for some people they
recommend not doing this at the start to
save on time so I'm kind of at the camp
that if you're in the very beginning
stages you're not sure where things are
go gonna go if you're short on time then
I would recommend saving the unit test
for later but happy to discuss that
later as well
okay all right so let's get into some
general concepts about unit testing
so there's more that can go into this
but just for the sake of time going to
group this into four
um High categories and starting with
clean code
so in this presentation today I'm just
going through a very basic example of a
class that I wrote called produce
insights very basic it's not really like
anything at all but just something for
for demonstration purposes but the
purpose of this class is to be able to
take in produce sales information and do
some sort of calculation giving that
data so with this example code here we
can see
um that in general when it comes to
testing we want to have our code
organized in a clean manner so instead
of having everything within let's say a
single large script or a notebook for
example where you're not organizing
things into different methods you'll
want to clean that up a little bit first
to have distinct units or your methods
that you're writing you can organize
those into classes depending on what is
appropriate and key thing is for each of
these methods that you write you want to
ensure that you have doc strings which I
know is very basic but just a reminder
for everyone that these are always
helpful for making sure that we
understand what the purpose of a
function is as well as what the expected
input outputs are but type hinting as
well to make it easier to know what the
expected type is for for anything that's
coming in and out of a method
I just want to also mention that there's
a lot of different styles for Doc
strings as some of you may be aware so
just use whatever is preferred by
whoever you're working with or if you
get to set that preference yourself just
use whatever you like
okay
so when it comes to writing the test
themselves the tests are usually written
as another method so we have a pi file
that's specifically holding our test and
we Define our tests as let's say test
underscore aim of our function and
whether that's going to be happy path as
in if that's for how the performance
should be if things are working as
expected like in terms of the input
being correct
um or exceptions like if things are put
in incorrectly what's the expected
output
so for all these tests
we
there's a few different ways of writing
these but I prefer the Three A's method
where we start with a range
moving to act and then go into assert
so what we're showing here is that in
this test we have here
we have this arranged section which
which focuses on organizing any sort of
input that would be passed into the
function itself so we're testing a
method called Low data here as you can
see with the name test load data
so the method load data from our produce
insights class takes in some sort of
data path and in the range section we're
just setting that data path to some
some path locally that we have Source
data in
and the expected output we're just going
to be reading then that in as well and
then arranging that here such that when
we get to act we can load in that data
path
and lastly for assert this is where the
actual functionality of the test happens
this is making sure that the output that
we get is as we expect given the input
so in general when it comes to tests we
follow this basic structure
right so what is data science without
data we got to have data right so
when it comes to working with tests we
are focusing on testing the
functionality of those methods
themselves and not necessarily about you
know what is the
um what are the actual values we're
getting all the data what is the
confidence it's more about the
functionality
so we don't necessarily need to nor do
we want to
run a test using the full data each time
that would be really inefficient and
take a long time and in addition tests
are usually run locally as well
so that data has to be stored locally
depending on the size of data that
you're working with it's not really
feasible to check in all that data into
a give repo like you would not want to
do that so for sample data we usually
either take a subset of our existing
data
or use open source data or create
synthetic data
just a thing to note is depending on the
data you're working with it's likely
that you won't be able to sort that
directly into the repo for privacy or
security reasons for for good for good
good reason and so when it comes to
determining a sample data set to use for
testing you want to make sure it's
representative of what you would
actually be running the full code on and
also covers edge cases as well
so when it comes to selecting samples
you got to make sure you have a good
distribution
and if you're using open source data
just make sure it has the appropriate
licensing and when it comes to synthetic
data just make sure you're covering
those different cases
so in terms of an example of sample data
I had to use recently this is a project
I've worked on where I was contributing
to an open source python package called
Presidio
so Presidio is for data
de-identification and they have an image
the identifier in beta but I realized
there wasn't any sort of compatibility
for medical images since those are of a
different image format
so I was working on this dicom medical
image redactor so for redacting any sort
of sensitive text note that this is
using open source data so what we're
seeing here is not actual patient
information it's synthetic patient
information but with the solution here
when I was ready to submit this to the
open source Library I needed to make
sure I had some sort of data with it to
be able to test the functionality and
proof to this open source Library hey
what I'm adding into your package here
actually works and will work
consistently
so the data that I use for development
and as well for in the unit testing is
this open source data set from the
cancer Imaging archive specifically for
like evaluating DiCon dicom
de-identification
so the license on here was good for us
to be able to use it but just to make
sure I also reached out to the data
owners to see if they're comfortable
with us using a subset other data to
host within the repo for testing and
demonstration purposes
so luckily they were really excited
about it all good and so we have the
data within the repository for the test
being run
so when we were interested in getting
that data into the repository as long as
well with the the unit tests that was
done via of course a pull request into
the public Repository
and so through pull request or PR builds
you can use that to automatically
validate that your tests are passing
before you merge any sort of code into
your main functioning branch
so this is typically set as a policy
within whatever platform you use whether
that's gitlab GitHub Azure devops
whatever you have and this is just a
nice way to ensure that you're never
going to be making a change to a branch
permanently that is going to or not
permanently sorry now they can get
changed to one of your main functioning
branches that's going to cause any sort
of breakages
so this is great because it blocks PR's
from being merged in if tests are not
passing but it's also a great way not
just for you to see if your changes to
your own code are no longer going to be
um you know working with the code in the
repository but it's great for
collaborative collaborative purposes as
well
if you are working on someone else's
code for example let's say someone has a
function within the repository that you
want to expand upon or you feel that
there's some edits that could be made to
fix a bug
you want to ensure that whatever changes
you're making don't break the unit tests
that are being run on that function
unless you feel the unit test itself is
flawed then you can change that as well
but it's really great for being able to
ensure quality when working for yourself
and also with others
all right so going into specific writing
techniques these are basic techniques
that can be applied for unit testing in
general but I'll be going through this
through the lens of data science
projects
all right so let's start off with
fixtures
so on the right hand side we have an
example of a test or actually sorry part
of the test python file where we're
seeing multiple different tests so
because we're working with that produce
insights class there's multiple methods
within a class typically
so if we're testing multiple methods
within a class that means we're going to
be using an object of that class you
know multiple times and to reduce
redundancy we can create a fixture or an
object of that class and just use that
one fixture throughout the whole test
test Suite
so up here we have a definition for a
produce picture that's going to be an
object of our produce insights class
and so this fixture itself is going to
be passed in to the different tests that
we have in this case we have two
examples we're testing calculate price
and also load data which both need an
object of produce insights
so in this case we can see that it's
just passed in as an argument
within each of these tests here which is
great because we don't even have to
specify it within the arrange section
because it's coming in already as an
input argument
another great thing about fixtures is
that you can modify the scope depending
on what's appropriate or needed for for
your testing so if you have let's say a
suite of code you have like 10 python
like dot Pi scripts and they're
organized in a certain way but let's say
there's a certain object they're using
quite a bit throughout those different
sorts of those different files you can
actually specify a fixture outside of
your test file in a different file and
then just import it and kind of use that
across different tests as well so really
great it's not contained to just within
one single test file
okay so next up we have parameterization
so I personally find this really helpful
especially for for working with data
since there's a lot of different cases
we will work with the same function will
need to work with different sorts of
um like different values and the
expected output the way it's processed
should be the same but we want to make
sure we can work with with that data so
for parameterization it's a way of being
able to point out different sets of that
input to pass through a function without
having to write multiple tests so
instead of saying test load data one
test load data condition two test load
data condition three and having a
different method for each of those we
just have one test load data and set in
sets of parameters
so with this example we have at the top
we're marking this as parameterization
these two things here are the different
arguments that we're parametizing for
this test
for this test we are loading in
um First Data path
and then also expected error type since
we're testing exceptions in this case
so let's say for for load data we need
the path as something that goes into the
function itself and in this case we can
see that we're testing it or passing in
three sets of input first we have some
non-existent CSV file another
non-existent CSV file Etc since we're
testing exceptions
and then second within each of these
pairs is the expected error type that we
would see from this given input
so just in general when it comes to
parameterization you first set a string
that lets us know what the arguments
we're going to be passing in are what
they're called
and then following that we have a list
just showing different tuples of that
input sets and so this is actually
parameterizing what's being sent into
the test method itself
so as we can see at first we have the
produce fixture as we saw in the
previous few slides being identified
first and then after that we see the
different arguments from
parameterization being passed in
so here we can see that data path here
corresponds to data path within this
test argument
unexpected error type here corresponds
with expected error type here within the
arguments for the test
so this is particularly helpful for
multiple cases when you're working with
a happy path for example you may want to
add in let's say another three different
sets of input that are kind of General
sorts of data that you would expect and
then maybe you also want to put in a few
different edge cases that you would
expect to not lead to failure but still
be processed correctly so that's a great
way to test multiple conditions
building upon this we saw that this was
an exception test rather than a happy
path test so just to kind of reiterate
happy path is when you feed an input
that you expect to work properly and you
would expect the output to to be you
know whatever you expected but for
exceptions that's when the input into
the the method you're testing would lead
to some sort of error and so in this
case this is the same as what we saw in
the previous slide but now we can see
further down that the test itself has an
empty range because there's nothing we
really need to to kind of prepare and
then when it comes to act we're feeding
in that data path
um that is being parameterized so the
first time this test is run this set
non-existent file dot CSV is passed in
um so once that's done
the um the way that this is formatted is
such that when an error is thrown we
kind of collect what error type that is
and we're going to compare that against
the expected error type
there may be different ways that you
want to actually test exceptions but
this is just a simple way so this is
helpful in cases where by default let's
say there's some sort of situation with
your method that would fail but by
default the error message that you get
from whatever small minor thing that
fails is not really helpful for the user
to understand like what's actually going
on so when you write specific um
value rate or so not value sorry um
exception raises within your code itself
this is just a test to make sure that
those expected
um error messages are provided back to
the user
all right so the next concept is
something that took me a while to get
used to so it's going to take a few more
slides looking back it's actually not
all that bad but I think I struggled
quite a bit with it at the start because
the documentation was um cut didn't
really cover everything extensively from
like a data scientist lens
um and so I want to be able to share
this in a way that hopefully is easily
digestible for everyone I think the
trickiness really comes more about the
implementation and specific tricky
things that happen here and there
um when you need to use this in a real
world setting but in this example
let's look at one of the methods within
our class itself not a test this is just
something within produce insights
so here
we have our method that we're going to
be testing let's call this process and
update update data
so we're going to consider this our
primary method that we want to test
we can see that within here it takes in
some arguments argument one argument two
process the data some way and the way
that it does that is it calls another
method within itself within the produce
insights class called calculate price
and then it applies some complex
transformation that's actually an
imported method from some other from
some other file or some other Library
then lastly we're going to update the
results that are attached to the object
itself so this is a very simple example
but the general concept here definitely
is applicable for all sorts of
situations so here we can see that
there's intermediary methods or we can
call them secondary methods within our
primary method but when it comes to
testing this
we are interested in just testing this
main method we're not necessarily
interested in testing these smaller
methods that are within it so how do we
go about this
so this is where mocking comes into play
so mocking is a way of essentially
preventing calls to those intimate
intermediary functions and instead just
patching it with some sort of expected
return value
so when it comes to the test as we see
on the right
with the test we can see that a mocker
object is passed into the test itself so
this is something that is just available
through Pi test mocker and so you just
pass this in and within your arrange
section in addition to Preparing the
inputs to the to the function you'll
want to do your Mac or marker.patch
calls as well
so how this works is with mocker.patch
you specify
the specific method that you're going to
be mocking so in the case of the code
we're looking at previously this was
located in the source folder source
utils produce.pi
and within produce.pi we have the
products produce insights class and
within that we had to calculate price
so that's pretty straightforward we we
have the um
kind of linkage to to that specific
method there and we're going to say that
for that intermediary function calculate
price we're just going to return an
empty data frame
similarly for the complex transformation
we're going to be doing the same thing
but note that here we can see it's
Source utils produce dot complex
transformation but the original location
of this complex transformation is
somewhere else if you note back from the
few slides ago complex transformation
was imported from some other location
but what we're noticing what we're
putting here is the specific reference
to it within the um the class that we're
working with not the original location
and so similarly here we're specifying
an output data frame of being empty so
instead of actually running this we'll
just be returning this
um and so when it comes to the
smoker.patch calls we want to make sure
that they're actually called and that's
what we can do in the assert section in
addition to asserting that the actual
outcome is what we expect it to be
so
what does this actually look like
let's go back to that method
so here's that original code that we're
looking at before
and if we apply those marker.patches
it's effectively this
so you can see that the calls to those
methods are replaced with whatever
return values we specified and this is
really great for ensuring that we're
testing what we want to test and also
reducing test time as well let's say
complex transformation is something that
takes like multiple minutes we don't
want to have to run that every single
time we're running a test of process and
update data especially for running
multiple sets of input for this test
itself because that can really escalate
quickly
so this is a great way to ensure that we
are specific in what we're testing and
also saving time as well all right
and so mocking's great but it's not
something we should do absolutely every
single time we're working with something
so we want to ensure that when we're
mocking we want to Mark we we do want to
mock imported Library calls so things
like I don't know anything like
scikit-learn or Pi torch and things like
that if it's like an actual imported
function from a library that exists
we'll want to mock that because usually
those are already tested
when it comes to test to code that we've
already written that has tests written
for it as well we can mock those like in
the example we just provided
and any sort of calls to external
Services we also typically want to mock
given that test should be able to run
locally
if you have any sort of connection to a
database for example as private data
loading or any sort of external calls
like that API calls you want to be able
to mock those so you don't need to do
those external connections so we can
talk more about that as well than q a or
office hours
however you do not want to mock really
basic things that are essential to the
operation of your function that you're
testing itself
so if you have any sort of methods that
you don't have tests for yet write those
tests don't mock those yet
and any sort of basic operations so
let's say getting like shape of
something addition or whatever you don't
need a mock like the small things so
when it comes to mocking it's really
crucial but you also don't want to go
overboard with what you're kind of
patching out
and I'll hold here just for a second as
the photos being taken sorry
all right and then um all right so we're
running a little fast apologies but this
leaves more time for questions
um so just in overview the value of unit
testing for data science code is that it
really helps for writing production
ready code there's more to it than just
unit testing but it is really a key part
of it it helps promote quality for any
sort of solutions you're writing for
yourself or with others and it helps
prevent Downstream headaches as well I
will say there's multiple instances
where unit testing really helped me
clean up like notice certain situations
with my code where let's say I wasn't
accounting for a particular Edge case or
I accidentally hard-coded something and
that was affecting the results
Downstream like this was a great way to
catch that ahead of time and prevent any
sort of Downstream headache
and lastly in a collaborative
environment essential and really really
helpful so when working with other
people's code when working with your own
code down the stream as well it's been
really really helpful for that and for
example any sort of contributions to
open source libraries as well or for any
sort of solutions you're writing you'll
want to have unit tests
so just as a takeaway is that unit
testing is not just for software
Engineers but you know for data
scientists too so I want everyone here
to feel confident in their ability to
start writing tests if you're not
already and if you have been writing
tests hopefully what I shared has been
has been helpful
and I want to have this slide up real
quick for anyone who might want to take
pictures for resources that are helpful
so the example code that I use within
this repository is also available to
Source three there's
um just a lot of different resources now
available for this that weren't
available a few years ago so
um
definitely take a picture if you have if
you have a moment and are just in this
and
hold that up all right I think one other
person's taking a picture
okay
all right
um and just want to say thank you
everyone
[Music]